and then so recently i started
seeing someone it's like we're on like
date three now and i like him he's like
really nice i really like this guy
actually every guy that's seeing her
right now is like that's me yeah oh my
gosh
like when i'm dating someone and i
really like them i'm a constant like
okay good news you're a stage five
player
cleaner over here for sure
you like become a fan of the person
you're dating
that's weird
yeah you're [ __ ] me i'm like a talker
so
see i need other people's opinions to be
like where do i get 15 minutes
yeah like i'm looking and like why would
you look for 15 minutes it's happening
ask someone so you don't shoot yourself
i could well what if i have to [ __ ] and
i asked somebody they're showing me and
i'm like
[Laughter]
you're a strange little thing wow
[Music]
hello welcome back to big mood everybody
we are here the four of us together
again like
power ranger i know there's five of them
like um friends oh that's six ninja
turtles
what's the planet captain planet i was
thinking about that
fire or water i think there's heart
though too that's five yeah
tips i'm watering there's earth
air no i'm not no you're more earth
you're more grounded
you think you think jess is probably you
win your win [ __ ]
anyway yeah you're grounded you're your
earth
you could be heart but nobody wants to
be heart so i don't want to give that to
you maybe i have a heart
okay i guess everyone wants to be heart
wow
the youtube really doesn't leave you
doesn't
know exactly
we used to have like green pops when i
was a kid and pretend to be the little
cold i don't know why
my extremities get cold because you
don't have a heart
some water [ __ ] oh my god i'm the
atlanta cancer here so i'm using scorpio
we're way more water than cancers uh i'm
a crab literally in the water i know but
like takes me out of the water signs it
makes me angry that aquarius is not a
water water yeah
that's really annoying i know in scorpio
it should be desert yeah but we're water
well we're like the wateriest of the
water science well desert isn't it or
earth i guess would that be yeah yeah it
should be dark i feel like scorpions
remind me of fire though like they feel
remembered like tequila and fire they
make me think of dirt anyway anyway so i
started dating again you're [ __ ]
dirty i want to hear this i want to hear
something interesting about it is that
you're actually dating did you think
about that because jess said she was a
crab and
it's all crabby
yeah that sure so your dating life is
not going well tell me about it well
nothing's going well it's just that i'm
rusty now
oh you rusty [ __ ] you've barely been
out of the dating game i don't know how
to
i don't i just don't know how to like
flirt or how did you meet was it like uh
one of the dating app things or was it
like through actually are we talking
about a person or multiple people uh i
mean like dating in general i've been
meeting people through friends i tried
dating apps for a little bit
and it's just like a series of first
dates or like a few dates and i'm like
oh i thought you met somebody
um no i'm like in the middle of like
have you taken your solo girl time
because you're supposed to do this yeah
i only started dating so i've been
single since november i only started
dating around like this month
okay the it was recent no that's not
that was like seven six months ago i
don't know i'm like i'm just dipping my
feet in the water again yeah like i went
on a first date with this one i think
it's because i'm a lot more picky and
critical now yeah because [ __ ] people
girls so critical enough standards
you're following in my footsteps
like the first
time i went on a date your eyes are open
to the reality yeah seriously
what is it red pill you've taken
yeah
uh this one guy he wouldn't he just
didn't blink when he talked oh
weird okay and then like his eyes are
all red and water
[Applause]
he's like you're so beautiful i can't
stop looking at you i read yesterday
that eye contact's important
he forgot to believe someone gave him a
note like you need to make more eye
contact he's just like he doesn't drop
it ever now yeah
um and then like i and then whenever i
said something he would explain it back
to me what yeah
oh maybe he's got like a yeah that's
what i was thinking i don't know a
little spectrum or something i don't
know maybe i don't know give an example
okay so ask me my or
what's your favorite color
teal teal yeah that's a really nice
color because it looks like this kind of
stuff i can see why you would like that
because like it's a really natural color
like he's explaining to you yeah i don't
know i know someone like that yeah i
know someone like
it gets old real quick drop the name
oh you don't know from jail
so then like i've learned to cut off
people a lot easier now too
like i'm not much of a people pleaser
anymore so i'm kind of like i don't like
you so i just texted him i was like hey
you know you're cool but i didn't really
feel a romantic connection he's like
okay that's cool
and the next one
um so what would you have done
previously this is pretty normal
oh just like
i'll just talk in touch like i try this
new thing have you heard of it it's like
why are you just telling people
yeah
originally
then i'll just kind of quietly disappear
that's just ghost people that's annoying
yeah yeah thank you for not being
annoying yeah
and then like the person after that
spent like 20 minutes talking about nfts
i'm like okay
cool guys don't know that that's not
romantic talk that's like talk with your
buds or if i ask you about it yeah i
know but this is not how to get into my
painting no but it's fine i just go yeah
i just i let them go disagree with that
because
we will naturally filter people out like
because if you were in the nft's whoa
you found yourself there we go like so
that's what i feel like
the conversation at dinner could be like
i'm really into nfts and the girl could
be like cool i'm not and then now we can
talk about something else yeah
or did you make it sound like you're
interested i was like oh yeah that's
cool that's about it really yeah he just
kept going and he kept going yeah and
then just like his whole entire thing is
nfts maybe he heard
yeah that's cool yeah
yeah um and then so recently i started
seeing someone it's like we're on like
date three now and i like him he's like
really nice i really like this guy
actually probably my favorite one okay
and then i realized i don't know how to
text anymore
why because
yeah because i actually like this one
why do you like him um he could be gone
by the time this comes out but right
yeah who knows he's like he's really
sweet he uh plus every guy that's seeing
her right now is like that's me yeah oh
my gosh
they're all five of you it could be yeah
just kidding so though there is only one
because i'm too lazy to deal with i know
you can barely even have friends exactly
yeah
um
always the shade and it's like he's so
nice and he's a very cold she was
wearing them
yeah he's a very like calming energy
which i really enjoy you need that he's
older he's like 37. okay okay um
yeah right
he's old god he is so
almost rejected
i'm about to be 36.
older than me i didn't say he's old he's
older than me he's older that's all
that's what i'm saying he's older he
said he's not yeah older i think
i was like
oh like 10 years older than you
eight years old he's still older
yeah steve's older than me too he's like
six months older than him
i would say casey's older than me
because he's like two or three years
older than you yeah um okay
you call him an older man i would say
he's older he's older he's old [ __ ] no
you are literally older if you're born
yeah they're yeah
[Applause]
right
what else about this guy besides his
ancient bubble just because someone has
health insurance doesn't mean they're
old gina
um i like him because he's like a very
calming energy he's like the very like
nurturing i realized
my type of guy
that i can i can finally put it into
words easier now it's my type of guy is
the don't worry i got i got or don't
worry i got her don't worry i'll take
care of sugar daddy no no not like okay
sorry monetary okay just like
more like oh yeah attentive yeah or you
can go to dinner i made reservations for
tomorrow i'll pick you up at seven be
ready
to go you mean you're taking a child
yeah
um and he's but the thing is like i
don't know how to
talk to people anymore once i what do
you mean you don't know how to talk
because i like them it's like so what
are you saying now no because once i
like them i'm like why it's to me in my
head's like why aren't you [ __ ]
obsessed with me i'm out
oh my god sabotage no one more like
oh like i don't like he didn't text me
good morning today
what what how many dates have you been
okay with what you've been on two dates
gina i know oh my god i don't understand
timelines anymore you know what he's
saying he's like yeah she's a little
young like i mean she's just she's
younger but she's also young for her age
yeah right she likes to look like good
morning texts like literally but just
about this [ __ ]
i don't understand timelines anymore
wait do you tell him this you're like no
morning okay
can we okay give me another thing what's
what else because that's just crazy
like what else about what like what what
makes you feel like you don't know how
to no i don't want to agree with jess
and i have to go jess right now you know
like oh like do i do it too much okay i
just got off work how you doing today
how's your day you know like is it too
much is it too little am i like how how
often are we supposed to see each other
well how does that work
though yeah he does like sometimes he
but he's like one of those like quiet
korean guys
you know so i'm like
i don't know if i should
do you feel like you need to do more
than you would do with your friends no
you mean more than nothing yeah
more than nothing what is more than zero
yeah i was just like i don't know how to
um i think you should just let him
like especially since you wanted him to
take the initiative and he's overall
yeah you gotta have that mommy that's
true well he planned the first date i
planned the second one
no i planned the first one he planned
the second one now this one's mine i'm
gonna see what happens after the third
day these are taking turns yeah what did
you guys do what do you want him to text
you every morning and say good morning
oh who's high maintenance now
that's what i'm saying
i don't think i'm high maintenance at
all because i don't not even in your
relationship yeah like i don't expect
that when he does it it's really sweet
but i just
don't
like think about it like if he didn't do
it i wouldn't be like where's my good
morning dick sometimes he'll leave to la
and like he won't text me for like three
days or like he'll facetime me
and then he'll be like
um
i'll call him and i'll be like hey i'm
thinking about you and like oh my god
i've been thinking about you all day i
thought you were playing poker so i
didn't want to bother you or whatever
like sometimes he does call me during
poker and i'll be like i don't know
playing poker i'll call you later
um so yeah i just i guess i just don't
think about
well also because you guys have been
married for like five hundred years
like i don't i guess like if i texted a
person and they didn't respond back
quickly enough like yeah like 18 hours
yeah exactly if it was like the next day
and you guys freaked out after 18 hours
yeah yeah how long for you 30 minutes
how long is long jesus oh you're on the
spot or two
no maybe like a couple hours
is that short
yeah it's a little short
actually what if there is another doing
something you need to know their pattern
yeah
right they're texting
uh consistency
so it's a little pattern like breaks
doesn't yeah when the pattern breaks
yeah that's when something's up so i
think that's what i'm trying to figure
out right now because me
like when i'm dating someone and i
really like them i'm a constant like
okay good news you're a stage five
player
cleaner over here for sure
like i've been just like like how you
can tell when i like someone when i'm
just like what you doing you know like i
just want to know like what's going on
what's up what are you doing
you know okay fine cheers
but in relationship romantic
relationships okay we're in a romantic
relationship
[Laughter]
they're so needy gross
you like become a fan of the person
you're dating
that's weird
yeah you're [ __ ] me i'm like a talker
so okay so there's such an [ __ ]
see i need other people's opinions to be
like where do i you know like
well this could happen in our group chat
if you ever decided to
say
this is true you got to take the average
of our three answers and you'll get the
right answer yeah yeah
well just pick mine because no
it's pretty good yeah two married people
and a very well person
oh you're so woke
but so you know i'm like i'm figuring
out dating again especially after like
the whole like
big eye-opening
trauma and everything that happens i'm
like i'm trying to learn
you know how to do this break your
pattern yeah healthily oh i know why you
called him older now because i was like
oh yeah her past dude was like 24.
21. this much older
one of them was only like a few months
younger than that oh that doesn't count
he acted like he was [ __ ] 12. no he
definitely mentally he was in january
24. yeah
so yeah you know i'm just trying to
figure that out and um just you know i i
would go on dates and then just date one
person at a time i'm like yeah it's not
gonna work out and try someone else but
also the same time like if it doesn't
work that doesn't work and it's kind of
cool yeah because i'm so [ __ ] busy it
doesn't matter but i wanna know how
you're so busy and still like wanna text
him 24 7 and need him to reply within
two hours because when it comes to
filming it's just lots of people sitting
around waiting
oh is it
he still ghosts me
tim she's taking notes for when you
don't respond to her
[Laughter]
she's like yeah i saw your text yeah
and what
her text message is gina i need you to
read this ad okay
she's like i don't want to do work while
i'm at work no that's true that what
like the times that i have texted you
for not work related you do respond
really yeah so clearly she doesn't want
to do work yeah clearly i just don't
want to do work yeah but yeah so i'm
just trying to figure that out and like
you know like do i talk to people more
do i don't but it's been it's been an
interesting you know i've i've i'm
having fun just
meeting new people
you know
um and it's just nice to just like okay
i know what i want what i don't want you
know so it's it's it's been fun today's
episode is sponsored by honey the easy
way to save when shopping on your iphone
or computer thanks to honey manually
searching for coupon codes is a thing of
the past honey is a free shopping tool
that scours the internet for promo codes
and applies the best one it finds in
your cart here's how it works when
you're shopping on one of your favorite
sites at checkout the honey button
appears and all you have to do is click
apply coupons wait a few seconds as
honey searches for coupons it can find
for that site if honey finds a working
coupon you'll watch the prices drop
honey doesn't just work on desktop it
also works on iphone too
just activate it on safari and your
phone and save on the go i like to shop
online a lot because i don't really like
to go outside and every time i check out
there's always a honey button there and
it lets me save so much money because it
finds coupons like first customer
coupons or holiday coupons for me
without me having to search for it if
you don't already have honey you could
be straight up just missing out and by
getting it you'll be doing yourself a
solid and supporting the show the best
part is it's free so get honey for free
at joinhoney.com big mood that's
joinhoney.com big mood
so in the last few years we've had to
cancel a few too many get-togethers with
friends but not this year okay we're
back baby and it's time to party so you
better return like a hero with something
delicious something delicious from milk
bar for those of you who don't know what
milk bar is oh my god get with it
because it's like the best tasting
desserts ever i've had a few of their
products i've had their cookies their
birthday cake cookie especially holy
moly um but most recently their
strawberry shortcake truffles oh my gosh
you put it in the fridge you pop them
out when you want something sweet and
you cannot stop you maybe you should
stop they do a good job of packaging
them in like sets of threes so maybe you
don't eat the whole thing but oh my gosh
i brought them to a barbecue the other
day it was a swimming pool party and um
everyone's bringing like beers and stuff
you know what i brought milk bar milk
bar strawberry shortcake truffles and
everybody loved me that's right milk bar
is the perfect gift for anyone and
everyone in your life from birthdays to
graduations to summer cookouts or just
because
hey why not i eat them just because
every milk bar creation is made fresh
and then thoughtfully and beautifully
packaged so it arrives in perfect
condition ready to enjoy they offer fast
even overnight nationwide delivery and
right now milk bar has a special limited
time offer get ten dollars off any order
of fifty dollars or more when you go to
milk bar store slash big mood you'll get
10 bucks off an order of 50 by going to
milkbarstore.com
big mood milk bar store dot com slash
big mood
what is your definition of like someone
being obsessed with you and wouldn't
that turn you off after a little bit
true why are you doing it where's your
line
where are you people you mean like what
i said because yeah you like you're like
i want them to be obsessed with me no no
i don't care about that not like oh what
are you doing i want to be there
everybody else yeah not like not like
joe from you not like joe from youtube
but more like i miss you like let's hang
out this weekend like make plans like
constantly making plans and like doing
this and whatever you know you just want
someone to show general interest in you
okay
over time okay yeah not like i want to
wear your skin
that's pretty common but so you want
them to text you every morning
i like that's a little much okay
that's a lot i do that's i'm just trying
to like get into my like i'm the
i just want to know what you're looking
for so that i can help you out on what
to talk about well for me like it's a
huge communication thing so it's like
yeah i like good morning sex and i don't
need you to respond to me like after or
like if you just told me hey i'm gonna
be busy today um i'll text you after
work i'm like okay cool that's fine you
know what if i'm like hey i'm gonna be
busy today i'll text you after work and
then i don't text after work oh yeah
don't like that
yeah
we got really busy i forgot to text
after work follow through because text
messages only take a few seconds and i
know at one point in some time of the
day you're [ __ ] and you're sitting
there with your phone in your hands no
i was working while i was [ __ ]
on my phone
but yeah
maybe it's just because i'm a big texter
you know when it comes to relationships
yeah when it comes to romantic
relationships you're not [ __ ] me
because that's what it takes to be your
friend i literally just had your nipples
in front of my face today it's true and
i drink your breast milk yeah see we
exchange bodily fluids we're in a very
committed relationship this is true this
is true this is true i'm not with you
don't worry
i'm gonna analyze you though do you
think that you're really that big of a
texture do you feel like you really just
need validation constantly because
you're afraid
what they're doing no no based on what
you're based on what's happened to you
no no because like needing them to text
you every single day that would make all
the time i'm like why why and if they
say oh i'm busy i'll text you later and
if they happen not to then your heart
starts to race and it's like yeah like
it's like trauma oh yeah it might be huh
yeah well i'm learning so much about
myself
yeah especially if it goes a few hours
they said they were gonna text you and
then they don't you're just like i don't
like that because it probably like
triggers you from your trauma
well [ __ ] you've i mean you've had see a
very long series of bad things happen to
you in relationships so
that might you can't let that kind of
ruin it when you find like a good
level-headed 37 year old old man okay so
how do i like stop myself from over
correcting you know right
so like i'm trying to find that balance
i think it's like just whatever your
initial reaction is try to temper it and
maybe talk to someone else about it like
first yeah yeah like maybe be like
before we so i'm feeling like this right
now is this crazy right now like what
like what this is this is everything
that's happened this is what's leading
up to it and then if you know maybe just
kind of don't direct that towards him
right now cause we're gonna scare him
away yeah no i haven't i've been like
super chill about it and it's cool like
we're chill like he we were talking the
other night
and i was telling him like sometimes i
can't tell the difference between like
does this person like me because of who
i am or because of what i can give them
or
are they just nice to me and i have
trouble
i don't think so i don't think that
matters i don't think you should focus
on that yeah well because they're just
having that we were just having that
like just some casual conversation he
goes well gina okay well i'll let you
know right now i like you i was like oh
cool so that's cool you know i just like
open communication like that yeah yeah
well what guy's going to be like i like
you for what you can give to me no but
then no because they can just gloss over
and be like true that makes sense and
just not answering
up
yeah i don't know so you were waiting
yeah
she was
she's a masturbator
so um yeah do you tend to do that a lot
with your relationships like do you tend
to find yourself like testing no no
because i don't like people doing that
to me i don't like testing and i'm a big
i am i'm i hate people who try to um
hint things because i will faint
ignorance every time say it directly
yeah i do not like that at all yeah
neither um i like open communication
just like hey like i'll tell people hey
i like you you know and if it works out
it does if not then whatever
um but yeah that's a really good point
about the texting thing i should be
looking through that more
yeah and understand
what do you like dating jess because
sometimes you have posted in the group
chat like
he said this and like i've i don't know
you're kind of like over i feel like you
over analyze text what do you think like
do you still do that what is your
thought process when right guys over
time
okay so if a guy is texting you too much
you're like oh that's too much like
that's like he's giving he's doing too
much and then if they don't text you
enough you're like like well i said i
didn't want him to text me very much but
now he's not texting very much i don't
remember that yeah i remember that yeah
someone was texting me too much do you
remember when it was i'm trying to think
of who the guy was like
in the bones era
the guy was texting
so last fall
[Laughter]
it's
[Applause]
so i didn't actually date a magician not
anything against you you know that it's
not a serious relationship yet when your
friends only call them yeah
yeah the french guy but yeah yeah the
french friendly the magician say who my
favorite was all of them funny dad or
what is it um
he's actually picking up on instagram
now i was like damn i missed that train
now you're feeding into the just as a
gold digger yeah you know what's funny
is that they did that in sex in the city
and i didn't think real people did that
but then i'm like oh yeah we actually do
do that yeah yeah like give
nicknames for that yeah
we don't give a nickname for your guys
because i never really described them
yeah and plus you guys have only met
like
mine
yeah you're doing all these guys are
jokes they taste different flavors you
just kind of pick one and you want them
to be obsessed with you exactly yeah so
i just have one so i just have a buffet
so you guys need like a name yeah yeah
because these stories are more fun
yeah yeah because it's like a drama that
my favorite was still the french guy i
think oh yeah yeah yeah i could feel
that from you
because he was more grown he was like
the only one that felt like a grown ass
man yeah yeah
and i agree i think with my beauty
around
he did yeah yeah literally tossed you
around
no so the guy that she's talking about i
remember it was an incident thing or not
incident but like you were asking us if
it sounded like he was lying about
owning a house yeah
maybe he wasn't texting me too much i
don't remember no then he wasn't texting
you enough but and then we were like
well did you tell him you don't really
like to be texted and you're like yeah i
told him i don't like texting about
small chat i don't like yeah i'll talk
small talk trying to remember and then
but he wasn't texting you now he weren't
he was yeah
oh i think it's like a week went by and
because he was like trying to text me
every day kind of like gina like text me
every morning and then at lunch in the
afternoon and i'm like okay i'm i'm okay
i am at work like that's a lot oh like
three four times a day and then i was
like
i don't need it like yeah it's really
sweet when it happens but i don't like
need it i think it was yeah okay so i
think it was that he was he was yeah he
was just doing way too much when we
hadn't even really like
we hadn't even created like a she said
this
was like yeah he wasn't texting me too
much yeah he was waiting
for that i don't remember that but it's
i'm trying to get it to come back to me
but i think it was one week that this
situation happened so it didn't stand
out to me as yeah that was that guy's
situation it was just like this
then you told him to calm down i was
just like yeah i don't really like
texting so much and then like you know
like a whole week went by and he didn't
say anything at all so i was like okay
maybe i said it in a way that made him
think i didn't want him to text me ever
but i just meant like reel it in a
little bit but he reeled it all yeah
okay [ __ ] how do you tell someone like
don't text me every day because it's
bothering me but i do want you to still
communicate every few days or something
just only because like we were still
wondering men think women are
complicated very very i can't figure
this [ __ ] out
what is the math equation tell me the
algorithm
okay no not chat sorry i'm on stream
mode comments yeah tell us how often is
normal texting to you guys what do you
guys prefer through two or three weeks
of meeting a brand new stranger
you text it like maybe ever like a day
here maybe a day will go by where you
don't and then a day again later a
couple days maybe like it'll like it'll
escalate over time now i just met you on
friday and we're texting all day every
[ __ ] day now yeah like that's too
much yeah so i'm like maybe reel it back
let's talk a few times a week
gina that's too much okay
it's funny how the one because the ones
that like
don't that want to text all the time
with the friends because we're friends
yeah
we've involved our relationships
[Applause]
don't deny it when the group chat yeah
yeah like every single day yeah because
someone always had something to say like
there was always like topics popping off
yeah well because we were all new
friends yeah exactly me too it was juicy
times too it was juicy time it was very
different
it's true
but then like he said um
he's like he told me he's like i tend to
text a lot too and then sometimes i
wonder if i should like bring it back
and i was and like just
similar and i'm like
no first of all and where yeah you know
or maybe to him it's a lot yeah but to
me it's more he maybe he scared someone
off before yeah maybe so he's like oh i
texted her three times
i do remember that steve was the first
guy that would text me back right away
yeah like i was so used to guys just
like taking this
forever
that's the only reason
but i was like it was just like the
icing on the cake because it was like i
already felt like he was my soul mate
and one of the things that gave me a lot
of anxiety with other guys was that they
would take so long to respond
um
and then with him he like would always
respond right away and i was like see
it's not it's easy like it's easy to
just respond right away and it just made
things so much easier like because we
wouldn't talk forever we just like i
would say something silly like an inside
joke and he would like do a little bit
and that's it yeah i wanted to full
control so i do understand that part
yeah like if they take too long to
respond then i get like kind of annoyed
not two hours but like
unless it's just like a
hey i'm grabbing starbucks do you want
anything and then they take two hours to
respond like yeah that's too much but i
think a reasonable amount of time
if they don't respond in a reasonable
amount of time i get really if they
could just never be anxious if they can
just never keep the momentum that feels
like the relationship's growing yeah
like it just keeps kind of stop start
yeah that's what it is this has been a
good momentum yeah
i just don't think i think like when
guys do too much in the beginning i feel
like it's performative and it's love
bombing and i and i feel like i can see
right through it and there's that too
why are you like you're putting you're
laying this on so thick i'm like i don't
like it i feel like it's fake because
number one why would you be that like
doting and obsessed right away unless
you just don't have healthy yeah that is
really fake if you they just met you
yeah yeah
like with steve we had been friends for
three years so it was nothing was too
weird because it was like he already
knew me yeah so yeah so that's the other
scary side of dating like if they are
obsessed with me right away it's like it
is love bombing yeah yeah yeah then the
pride part of me is like love me now
yeah
you want them to be obsessed yeah so
it's it's yeah you want them to be
secretly obsessed there you go so you do
never
yeah
because he's always very particular
about how cool he comes off yeah oh yeah
that's true huh
yeah i mean yeah it's still early from
you oh you it's still early on so we'll
see i'm like joe the cat
i'm obsessed with joe the cat cat yeah i
am joe from you too joe the cat
that's like just peeing all over your
[ __ ] yeah looks like me mom yeah and
he's being a dina
it's true
so i'm like are you realizing things
like we're like i don't think like this
is going to scare me out from a
relationship like is that are you still
in that kind of head space no i'm still
in that kind of head space where it's
like there are certain things now
because i'm
so hyper focused on what i want for my
future and have a pretty clear vision of
what i want for my future and that if
i'm talking to someone and and we does
it just doesn't align yeah it's probably
not gonna work out okay so what would
work for you like because it probably is
not is it a guy with a nine to five or
like what does it look like um no so
i've always dated nine to fives and i'm
open to
the funny thing is like i'm open to
creatives now but then creatives don't
have the same lifestyle that i want
necessarily what's the lifestyle style
that you want i want my penthouse
you know what create it like i mean if
there's a difference yeah successfully
but it's like it's a it's a smaller pool
you know except to be nerdy and nerdy
ones aren't successful nerdy ones too
like it's a like there's a lot of things
that i think there's a dust thing that's
fun
[Laughter]
um
the way the best way i can explain it
now is like i
have a clearer version of vision of what
i want now
that i've just become a lot more
critical of the people that i meet which
i'm actually really thankful for that i
like i really like that a lot thank you
it makes me feel better
now because
because you actually have standards
welcome to the club
yeah i'm i'm slowly learning it's been
nice it's a nice growth process yeah
damn it's been so long since i've dated
i know i'm literally sitting here like
even the married couch were like you
were talking about like the beginning
i'm like [ __ ] how did casey and i text i
really don't remember you can't remember
i was very limited to experience with
people that i
didn't know before going on a date with
them
yeah you didn't date like strangers no
yeah never
i don't think ever like i feel like when
you guys met too like were people really
like texting all day every day or was it
still kind of like phones were a little
bit newer
like we feel like like eight years ago
right like weren't phones just invented
when you started
like are so much more in our life now
than they were
like a decade ago
it was just a sidekick that was
that was way before we started my
instagram in 2011. yeah we started
dating in 2012. and so yeah there's
plenty of time i had my iphone already i
had once i remember like i didn't text
that much back that was like 2007 to 9
is when the iphone was like kind of
maybe
us in the beginning texting i remember
you used to flirt
through text
i remember you used to do this cowboy
bit like hey they're pretty lady like
and i'll be like
hi
like [ __ ] i don't know how to flirt back
i do remember when you had to download a
separate keyboard for emojis and like
not a lot of people were using them and
i loved them and steve hated them
come through on his side no because
oh gosh i just remembered um so on a guy
that i had sex with a long time ago when
i was younger and then i like kind of
always had a crush on super toxic type
of guy um i he added me a linkedin
recently
and so i was messaging him or like i
added or i let him add me on linkedin
right like it's like you approved
approved it or whatever
and um like a week or two went by and
then i was like hmm so i messaged him
back and i was like hey long time no see
whatever and then we message back and
forth and then i was like this guy's
always been so toxic like he's like the
guy that why did you mess with your
guilty pleasure
because i was just like yeah i was kind
of like just poking at the bear a little
bit oh i see um but turns out he
admitted that he had a girlfriend so i
was like oh okay so i backed off and i
was like well if you're ever singing why
is he adding you i don't know girlfriend
yeah we're calling your girlfriend i
love you so he was he was the cop do you
remember that i [ __ ] up oh yeah
the joke that we had at the beginning of
the show yeah and um yeah i was just
like she was a cop [ __ ]
she booked two cops that's right two was
it two you said two yeah
wait who's the second two separate cops
you showed us pictures you put them in
the chat i remember oh no it was that my
first boyfriend became a cop oh that's
what happened after we were in high
school i had dated him in high school
and called her a cop [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah
specifically on purpose had sex with one
i have an update on uh the recent guy
that cheered on me the lawyer yeah i'm
like which one is a lawyer
um the girl that he chewed on me with
um who i warned her oh wait you said
this in the chat yeah right yeah wait
wait no i warned her
because like when i found out that he
was cheating on me with her i remember
how i messaged her yeah and warned her
because she was like she didn't really
believe me she was kind of making
excuses and she was kind of being kind
of like
a little [ __ ] about it she was but she
was also like 24 years old she's a child
yeah um she messaged me a couple weeks
ago saying hey i just want to reach out
and say um well my friends listen to
your podcast and i do too and i was like
okay
and she goes
um and i want to apologize for how i
acted because you were right you know i
kept seeing him and what you said
started happening and i was just
you know yeah no [ __ ] yeah yeah and then
i was like
i mean
i hate to did you respond oh yeah would
you say i said i mean i hate to say it
but i told you so yeah
what the [ __ ] do you want me to say you
know oh she listened to us now sorry
girl yeah i'm sorry sweetheart i'm not
sorry don't be a dumbass i told you
[Applause]
um
so she's like leave women he's like she
was like he was doing this and then he
started [ __ ] a 21 year old oh god
he's younger yeah younger what because
he's like 32 oh the midlife crisis he
should date younger girls based on how
mentally yeah
yeah immature he is when you say younger
that's like a good decade younger right
younger she was like yeah you know
um you'll never let it go she's like
she's like i found out because
er i found out he was [ __ ] her i
wasn't using a condom because he told me
one day he had a uti oh my god wait
you don't get utis from from that well
you got you can you really can't
no you two the guy like i can get you
wait you guys are you guys are they're
less common
yeah so he had a uti but it's not
sexually transmitted it just so happened
i guess he freaked out and he told her
he's like hey i just want to let you
know how you two are you can't pass it
to someone yeah you can't yeah it's not
contagious i mean like he's also not the
brightest person in the world is it
bacteria what is it it's just bacteria
that's built up in your liver
so you can't give the bacteria to
someone else no because they would have
to go into their urethra yeah like oh
yeah yeah it's not like you're saying
translation clearly
after sex which is gross but yeah he
told her and then she kind of grilled
him like dude what the [ __ ] and then he
admitted oh yeah i was [ __ ] this girl
without a condom she's like dude what
the [ __ ] we'd agree we agreed to be safe
yeah and then so it turned out to be
like some 21 year old girl wait didn't
you learn from your previous experience
that's what i'm saying the [ __ ] but like
i said not the brightest creature in the
world huh wow and then he wants to be
the the partner to be the next guy who's
left with a million people and chlamydia
part two
so this girl this this this the other
you know the other girl was like yeah so
i found out that way and you were right
he's so cheap like he like demands for
me to buy whatever he yells he hasn't
paid off all those attorney uh yeah
student loans yet and like he he has
like he gets angry if he has to plan
anything because he's like he forces me
to do everything and i was like
and at the end she goes i know you're
probably sitting there laughing about
this right now but i should just
probably let you know and i responded
like yeah i am laughing about this
i can empathize you know whatever [ __ ]
happens but yeah every 24 year old
wonder i wonder why she had to tell you
like why did she feel like okay
she listened to it on the show like gina
talked about the situation on the show
so
but um yeah i don't know
i'm like reach out to the ex-girlfriend
and then yeah yeah yeah i don't know she
doesn't have someone to do that yeah
it's very it's very strange maybe she
felt like you were um i don't know
eskimo sisters or something yeah
you could uh commiserate over him
together but it's like
yeah why would you come to me that's
weird that's that is weird i don't know
but then i was i was dying i was [ __ ]
in tears laughing when i sent a
screenshot to you guys
um and then a week later
um his ex-girlfriend the one before me
the one that i became friends with oh
yeah [ __ ] like she's also the the s
name he keeps calling you her name
yeah that one so she and i are homies
now it's [ __ ] cool she [ __ ] blew
up my phone a week ago she goes jenna
jada i'm like what she goes
i'm sitting at um it's a it's a shabby
restaurant that i love it's called
mokuji and she's like i'm sitting at the
bar at mokuji and he
was walking into the door with some
random young little girl looking kind of
thing 21 year old makeup on
and he saw me and turned around and
walked out immediately and i was like
holy [ __ ] i wonder when he told her all
of his exes are friends now right funny
you're so toxic that all your exes
became friends but like imagine being so
shitty that you can't go to a place yeah
i want to know the conversation he had
with that girl i know i want to know
what he said like yeah he can't eat
there you know because if he if i was a
young little child girl and he said oh i
can't go there because my
ex-girlfriend's in there you would not
have red flags he would not have yeah no
but the girl wouldn't like at that age
unless she's very self-aware and smart
like she would probably think oh yeah
she's a [ __ ] right yeah like [ __ ] her
i'm on your side you know but as you get
older you're like yeah yeah what did you
do to her why can't we go in this
restaurant right
i mean so i don't know what he was
saying imagine he's like oh we can't go
here because i can't afford it and
[ __ ] yeah right
she was already gonna pay anyway
she'll then mow him if he just pays for
him
so yeah so she blew up my phone i was
[ __ ] cracking up i was like dude
imagine if he actually did go in but he
didn't have the balls too like imagine
being so shy well is it like one of
those restaurants that's only got like a
few square feet and it's really long no
it's a pretty big one at each other it's
a pretty big one with an outside patio
it's like cheesecake factory
you can't even be in the same building
right because you know a lot of those
shopping restaurants are like just tiny
with that table a little tiny yeah
is he gonna just be like 20 feet from
you because i could be like i don't want
to sit you know 20 feet from
my ex you know like all
night weird
yeah that was the exciting updates of
that i'm randomly getting it's like okay
that's hilarious what do you think you
would have done if that was you in that
restaurant and he walked in and he
walked in yeah with that little girl
because i don't know like if i was
uh if you were that girlfriend oh she's
me now or maybe
right now right now stop you cheating
ass [ __ ]
you better run little girl he's like
thirty two you better
yeah did you ever show a photo of him
does anyone know who he is probably not
right
she did post them on her stories when i
rekindled yeah and i was like what yeah
i was like
so if anyone really someone might have
caught it yeah so if you really paid
attention but it's not like the
situation with reed where everyone knew
who he was no no no i never outed his
name yeah yeah so i mean there's plenty
of other but he was scared of [ __ ]
though he's like you better know because
i'm gonna sue you yeah i'm gonna sue you
for what for telling the truth yeah i
was like for what he goes for for
definition like do you realize you dated
me for two years and i know how to do
this and you taught me everything
from cringing at the pump to getting an
eye-popping check at your favorite
restaurant inflation is hitting us all
where it hurts and it really hurts
that's why i started using upside upside
is an incredible app for anyone who buys
gas groceries or dines out and with
every purchase i'm earning cash back
thanks to upside so recently casey and i
went to las vegas we went on a road trip
we took his tell your ride which means
we needed to pump lots of gas and gas
these days is nuts but luckily i had my
upside ready to go and at every station
that we stopped by to pump gas i was
earning back cents per gallon like at
one particular shell i remember we got
like 23 cents per gallon back
and since we were on a road trip we also
stopped by many restaurants and we i
remember getting up to like ten dollars
at a mcdonald's once where i'm like whoa
this is cool like i honestly thought
upside would be too good to be true but
it really isn't you guys upside is a
no-brainer to get started download the
free upside app in the app store or
google play use our promo code big mood
and get five dollars or more cash back
on your first purchase of ten dollars or
more next you claim an offer for
whatever you're buying on upside you
check in at the business you pay as
usual with a credit or debit card and
you get paid in comparison to credit
card rewards or loyalty programs you can
earn three times more cash back with
upside you can cash out anytime to your
bank account paypal or an e-gift card
for amazon or other brands upside users
are earning more than a million dollars
every week that's probably why they have
a 4.8 star rating on the app store so
download the free upsite app and use
promo code big mood to get five dollars
or more cash back on your first purchase
of ten dollars or more that's five
dollars or more cash back on your first
purchase of ten dollars or more using
promo code big mood when you know more
you can do more what if you could use
science to discover more about your body
find out what you need for your
healthier tomorrow with everly well
everly well is digital healthcare
designed for you all at an affordable
and transparent price with over 30
at-home lab tests you'll be able to
choose a test that makes the most sense
for you to get the answers you need like
the women's health test or the food
sensitivity test that's the one i chose
everly well also has high quality
vitamins and supplements to support your
overall health choose from a variety of
options including vitamin d3 and omega-3
fish oil here's how it works everly well
ships products straight to you with
everything needed in one package to take
your at-home lab test simply collect
your sample and use the included prepaid
shipping label to mail your test back to
a certified lab your physician-reviewed
results get sent to your phone or device
in just days and you can share the
results with your primary care physician
to help guide your next steps if you
order vitamins and supplements you can
start adding them to your daily routine
right away it's so simple over 1 million
people have trusted every will to
support their health and wellness goals
and you should too i actually got the
food sensitivity test because i have
been having gut issues and i can't
figure out why and it's been months and
months and months and i'm just like
going one way or the other with
stomachaches and other types of problems
and i'm hoping that i really will can at
least help me get started on the process
to see what i might be having sensitive
reaction to that way i can just go to my
doctor and say hey i got this done what
do you think for listeners of the show
everly well is offering a special
discount of 20 off and at home lab tests
at everlywell.com big mood that's
everlywell.com
big mood for 20 off your next at home
lab test everlywell.com big mood which
are wiser are you guys following the
johnny depp amber heard that lightly i
haven't read bits and pieces yeah me two
bits and pieces not the whole thing but
i don't know a terrible actress i know
she really is really bad like there's no
way it's like she really thinks she's
pulling this off yeah how it's really my
favorite thing i'm calling her right now
he's doing her right now yeah when it
was all dropped right
was it dropped like it was a defamation
case now i don't know who you brought it
back
um johnny depp is suing for definition
yeah
because he lost a lot of money off he
lost all our jobs
but my favorite thing on i only go on
tick tock right now just to look at
people like commenting on it or clips of
the trial
and i love seeing people reenact her
testimonies they're so funny [ __ ]
hilarious it's just but it's also like i
don't know like you really and then i've
seen also posts about like it'll be
amber heard from like this one
particular event and then like three
other pictures of like
women that are have been
battered like actually like women that
have gone through less than what she
claims she went through the day before
she took that
photo and she's like perfectly fine like
no
marks or nothing or just nothing but
then all these other women are like
bruised up like big like swollen eyes
and like it just makes you think like
if she really is
lying about all this like how she's
hurting the actual victims like yeah
she's [ __ ] it up for people that are
actually
been abused and then now they have to
like fully try to prove themselves
because now this [ __ ] is over here
lying and making it i mean we don't know
for sure though if she is well if that's
what i'm saying if yeah if she is and i
can only imagine shitty people will be
like yeah no i didn't beat her whatever
what if she's just pulling an amber hurt
exactly yeah right yeah that's what i
why i this trial is like hi i don't
really like it because
it's giving um it's just making it a
mockery of like
right these cases right and i do think
there is some like sadness to like oh
like you know she was believed right
away but then like maybe like there are
some exceptions where maybe there's like
a someone crying wolf you know but it's
not like i feel like it's more the
exception to the role but it's now gonna
be set as a precedent for whatever
whatever happens in this is going to set
a precedent for what could happen later
i do like abuse cases i do like that
it's bringing more light to abuse
against men
you know yeah that's like i like that
that's that's happening right now
because i have family members that were
uh dating crazy [ __ ] and they abused
you know yeah yeah
yeah that's not impossible yeah it does
happen
so i'm glad that it's that's coming out
and people are supporting johnny depp
and not calling him a little [ __ ] blah
blah blah whatever yeah so i like that
part of it
um there was i had to see a tick tock
where
what i don't remember which makeup brand
it was oh yeah i saw that but amber
heard said that she
used the certain makeup brand to cover
up the bruises back then or this like
this palette this palette and then that
makeup brand [ __ ] poster ticked out
saying this [ __ ] didn't come out until
like two years after that oh yeah it was
amazing yeah they they pretty much
caught her like why why would she even
use that exactly i don't understand like
she her it's just such a weird it's a
weird case feels like i need to dive
more into the details yeah
maybe i'll do a different there was like
a lot of um like stuff against johnny
and like he lost in the europe courts
twice like so i'm like what
what are we missing here why is everyone
immediately on johnny's side now all of
a sudden when he lost for years i don't
even know that he lost oh yeah he lost
like two cases in europe i think because
they live in the uk or something right
or he does i don't even know and then
why is the the current trial in virginia
or something like where i don't know
like why yeah i need to know i need to
know more details yeah why are there
multiple i don't know weird i didn't
know about that in the end maybe we can
read it more i kind of just started
watching
earlier things were circulating about
her [ __ ] in the bed yeah
honestly who shoots on a bed like
seriously you know like that's that's
that's what the hell is going on there
guys i've never been so mad at someone
that i would [ __ ] on something that is
not a toilet you know weird
trying to think if i've ever been i
don't even think i can [ __ ] on command
exactly
there or it's not there i don't
i live with a lot of anxiety and so i
don't think that it would be like a
really happy like swirly like regular
[ __ ] it's like kind of like an ibs [ __ ]
like a little like a little rabbit turd
like a little wrap
it wouldn't be when you're traveling and
like you can get a full poop out it
would be a very effective [ __ ] so it
would look like
[Laughter]
yeah because then for johnny to be like
it was human feces like how did no the
maid said it or something he wasn't
there when i'm mad dude like you know i
have to be like relaxed to [ __ ] like i
can't maybe she just maybe she took a
drink maybe she had a drink you pissed
the [ __ ] out of me yeah
i think we should uh look into it more
before speaking too much on it yeah
there's been so many other things that
have come out into people that can [ __ ]
on commands right
i want to learn more about this skill
really useful for some like escape
situations yeah if i got kidnapped and
they're about to rape me i'm going to
sharpen myself i will tell you that
anytime i've ever been either a locked
out of my house which has happened a
couple times i always immediately have
to [ __ ]
and talk to b
if i have to be in a certain grocery
aisle too long like i can't find the
ingredients i have to [ __ ]
those two things that trigger me
being in the grocery aisle too yeah like
if i can't find the [ __ ] item and i'm
in the aisle too long you're like where
it is
where's the confectioner's sugar
millions of years of evolution has done
this to you that's what that's
if i'm like god i'm really cosplaying i
gotta go nope i gotta get locked out of
my house or be in an aisle too long
somewhere out there back then during
hunter and gatherer years there's
nikki's ancestors who are [ __ ]
because they can't find the right
berries together they're like wrong
yeah that was the poison yeah
oh god damn i gotta be here like look at
these bears for so long
it's too long too like i want to know
your actually
yeah like i'm looking and like why would
you look for 15 minutes it's happening
ask someone so you don't shoot yourself
i could well what if i have to [ __ ] and
i asked somebody they showed me and i'm
like hi god
you're a
strange little thing wow that is
hilarious that is a funny thing that's
so funny
i don't know is it over there they're
like well let's look over here i'm like
okay
i'll be right back i'll be right back
they're like [ __ ] i'm trying to find
this canopy
you're worried too much about [ __ ]
that's not going to happen
no that happens
i just don't want someone to be tired i
want to test this out now
in a controlled experiment one we lock
her out of her home in two we sent her
into a market to find something that we
know is out there wait where do you [ __ ]
when you're locked out of your home so
it's it usually happened in childhood um
because i was latchkey kid and i
sometimes forgot to bring i have 80d i
forget to bring the house key oh yeah we
know so then i'm like locked out and i'm
like [ __ ] i would be out here until 5
p.m when my parents come home
and like i immediately have to [ __ ] now
it's like this pit in my stomach that's
like oh no like i don't have control
over the situation
i need to i am emptying my bowels your
parents probably thought the neighbor's
dog kept [ __ ] on their lawn this
whole time well did you ever
push the bush
houseless people that was just you right
yeah i just i'm like whenever it's the
most inconvenient you were the [ __ ]
[ __ ] jogger remember a few years ago
there was a jogger that kept sitting in
people's houses
no it was a guy wasn't it he was like
okay the couple of times i shouldn't
hang until it did come out like a swirl
it does yeah it was like that i was like
i was pretty impressed by it i was like
i don't think i've ever taken a swirly
[ __ ] like taking a squirrel poop i
thought that was only in
cartoons my dog sounds magical
my dad is pooping it just see what
happened
because he's talking about turns yeah i
guess i'm just saying i could definitely
never sit in the bed
that's the hashtag that name's never
gonna go away
i mean if she really did beat him then
[ __ ] call her that all day i don't
give [ __ ] yeah i don't know no how many
i don't know
yeah i don't i mean if you really did
[ __ ] in the bed you should be called
yeah for sure
i guess if you really did
i can't imagine amber really taking even
if you're a good person and you [ __ ] the
bed and now that's your name sorry yeah
so have you ever shut the bed
me no i can't i just said i i would i
don't can't [ __ ] on command i have to be
trapped somewhere we have to move
out
yeah
picture somebody [ __ ] outside i've seen
this way he's gonna give me a citation
it's a violation pictures of people who
get so drunk that they pass out and [ __ ]
and piss themselves i'm like i've never
i've been so drunk before i've never
done that yet i've never reversed myself
i think that means they lost
consciousness entirely right i don't
know like foreign
do people in comas [ __ ]
probably
i don't know they're doing this probably
they get a catheter
or a bedpan they get a bedpan no in a
coma maybe
no because you have to sit up there no
you don't
i use the pet bed pen for the first time
in my life when i was in labor with luca
where did they put it they just put it
under your butt so yeah i'm literally
laying down with a pan under my butt and
i had to pee and it was [ __ ] weird
that's weird yeah when i i thought i had
one because i couldn't you have to like
kind of get up and get into it yeah yeah
yeah but if you're in a coma you don't
get up no i mean they'll probably they
help or something i think
there's no they probably have diapers i
don't know don't they put the [ __ ] back
the [ __ ] is colostomy
i don't think they do that no they're
not they're not cutting holes for
someone in a coma i don't get to google
this i think it's their diapers
i think hold on yeah
because now i need to know what happens
to people in the country what happens to
me every day is that i'm thinking about
we're talking about amber heard and i'm
like how do people come with [ __ ] and
then i go into the [ __ ]
[ __ ] phil how do patients poop like i
guess what is
it i'm pretty sure it's a diaper okay
okay
bedpan was you went to the hospital
before so food is going to work with
patients food is going to be a tube okay
um
i know catheters for p for sure why
isn't there an easy answer right away
without googling it
sends me the randomest things like
randomness prompts i don't know what i
was saying a lot of them are from india
too a lot of them for india yeah what
the [ __ ] is that i don't know they're
from india i like that okay so yes they
still poop most are given a stool
softener so it will pass easily so 90 of
the time their poop is the consistency
of gravy some patients wear adult
diapers which are pretty difficult to
get situated correctly on someone that
is unconscious so there are special pads
and linens that we place under their ass
to help catch the poop oh i did have one
of those so they just they just in my
bed too like this it's like a dog
like the dog
leakage but this did not happen or
always catch at all i had patients that
[ __ ] in the floor or [ __ ] the floor
without leaving the bed sometimes the
patient will [ __ ] three or four times in
a shift it's a lot of fun when it
happens multiple patients across the 12
bed i see you oh it's just so much poo
why the [ __ ] aren't they given a
colostomy bag because you have to cut
the infection rates girl come on they're
in a coma you want to just clean [ __ ]
that's flying out from these things you
can't invade someone's body with a knife
i mean you can't but it's not also who
knows how long they'll be in the coma
what if it's like a two day coma and you
[ __ ] get him with colostomy back how
long did your two day comments
someone's butt isn't that a oh god i
don't think so what is that
it's called
yeah
um
what the poop
doesn't fit the yeah
what is
jesus christ would you guys ever poop on
someone's chest no no how about we say
that for the next piece again how do
people poop on command
how do you have [ __ ] ready to go because
you can time it if you take why do i act
like i know
you can you have like that you can take
a sienna whatever that [ __ ] leaf pill
those like those laxative pills it's
like oh you gotta commit wow
but then like what if you're in the
middle okay
play part you're the four player like oh
uh
yeah yeah
then you just skip to the mean time
how do you time it you know exactly
that's what i'm saying if you time it
too late it's like [ __ ]
is a skill yes or no leave us a comment
right
and then how often do you guys text i
don't know anymore man just [ __ ]
watch the episode
you have to practice that skill i
i don't know maybe a certain diet maybe
a certain diet
you could probably train it yeah and
you'd have to have enough fiber that it
can oh god all right guys well thank you
for watching make sure to check out our
sponsors
leave it uh leave your comments
sponsored by tushy before there's a lot
for you to comment on so get into the
discussion we love you bye bye
[Music]
so
[Music]
you